good evening everybody ladies and
gentlemen it is my pleasure to introduce
the finale of three Ghulam lectures
presented by Sam Bowles on how we got to
be nasty and nice the Elam lectures are
dedicated to the memory of
mathematicians Donna Slav Coulomb who
epitomized the kind of interdisciplinary
research now conducted at the Santa Fe
Institute long before the Institute was
founded I would also like to thank dr.
Penelope Penland for her generous
support of the coulomb lecture series
and I would also like to note that her
training is in psychology and she has
taken it upon herself to fund the kinds
of lectures that have a psychological
bent and if anyone is interested in
other types of research and isn't so
inclined I'm going to make a very very
yeah a pitch for anyone who would like
to contribute to the Santa Fe Institute
to support such lectures a small notice
many of you may also be regular
attendees of Santa Fe public lecture
series and I have been asked to let you
know that the public lectures in October
and November will not be at the regular
Wednesday times Fran's de Waal from
Emory University will be talking about
our inner ape on Tuesday October 7th and
Dan Gilbert from Harvard University
we'll talk about stumbling on happiness
on Monday November 17th tonight's
lecture is the third and grand finale of
three lectures by Sam Boles Sam Bowles
is a professor of the Santa Fe Institute
where he heads the Behavioral Sciences
program he is also a professor of
economics at the University of Siena Sam
earned his bachelor's degree at Yale in
1960 and then went to Harvard to earn
his PhD in economics so if you remember
in this first lecture he talked about
worthless academic credentials as a kind
of signal of an otherwise and I quote an
observable trait that is desirable in a
co-producer or coalition partner I think
Sam knew what he was talking about so in
his first lecture well Sam also taught
economics at Harvard from 1965 to 1973
at the University of Massachusetts
Amherst
he is now professor emeritus in his
first lecture on on Tuesday night Sam
described the unique kind of large-scale
cooperation observed among humans and
why it cannot simply be explained in
terms of such commonly proposed
arguments as kin selection self-interest
with long term time horizon or what we
simply fear someone is watching us in
his second lecture last night Sam took
up the problem of explaining why humans
might have such a huge propensity to
cooperate focusing on the coevolution of
two kinds of behavior altruism on the
one hand and parochialism on the other
in these lectures Sam has exemplified
the kind of research that makes you
testify such a unique place to do work
as many of you might know academia is a
place that if not characterized by
altruism is at least parochial
anthropologists have their own
departments journals conferences and
canons
economists sociologists and
psychologists have their own I haven't
even mentioned physicists because I'm
parochial myself in his own work Sam has
fought hard to break down these barriers
consider the collaboration of four
economists and twelve anthropologists he
described in it's Tuesday night lecture
for economists and twelve
anthropologists walk into a bar in many
circles this sounds like the beginning
of a bad joke but Sam and his colleagues
made it a productive model of research
and as a result have reinvigorated the
field of cross-cultural behavioral
studies the range of collaborations
required to collect and interpret the
data presented in the last two lectures
is astounding Sam has digested
ethnography experimental data archival
research hypothetical histories game
theoretic deduction genetics
archaeological data and a preponderance
of evidence if you remember on how
people dispatched one another in
prehistoric times
recall it's a broken ulna and not a
radius that indicates violent conflict
in his previous two lectures Sam has
argued that we are not always knaves and
he has proposed an explanation for this
sometimes I think Sam's deeper
motivation to study this topic is that
he doesn't feel like an idiot
and he doesn't like other economists
telling him that he is whether or not we
are nasty or nice is very interesting
from a scientific perspective
but in the scheme of things why does it
really matter whether we are knaves or
not why does it matter for policy or for
how we build societies or design
governments tonight's lecture is going
to take on that challenge from Sam's
record as a reformer and not just an
academic reformer but one who has fought
the loyalty oath at Harvard in 1960s who
debated Milton Friedman and Gary Becker
prominent Chicago school economist about
free markets on public television during
the Reagan era and who has served as an
economic adviser to Jesse Jackson Robert
Kennedy Nelson Mandela and the
International Labour Organization I
suspect this is where his heart really
lies and I look forward to hearing what
he has to tell us
well thank you all for thank you all for
coming and bearing with me this
difficult and demanding topic it's
actually more this topic today what I'll
be talking about today is more demanding
than you might think the first draft of
what I'm talking about
tonight I wrote in 1988 the same title
and I presented it at the philosophy
department at University College London
it was well received by them but not by
me but something did come of it because
it was about that time that I met my
wife and she told me later that that was
one of the reasons why she fell in love
with me that paper now of course that
worried me a lot because I I keep hoping
there was something else you know what
you see before you is a beautiful fresco
which is on the town hall in Siena Italy
and this is a painting in 1338 remember
that's that's 200 years before
Machiavelli in which Lorenzetti tried to
portray what a good society would look
like
it's a massive fresco and this is just a
small detail but what is absolutely
striking about it is it's entirely
secular it it conveys the idea of people
going about their business in a
well-ordered way peacefully productively
and so on and so at this time as had so
many times not only in Europe but in
other parts of the world
we've been troubled by how best are we
to organize our lives so that we can
live peacefully and productively
together now
I want to review a couple of things that
we've already established I think these
are things which I would show a little
picture of the hammer not the restor we
are a uniquely cooperative species we
join with large numbers of others
including non-kin in the pursuit of
projects for mutual benefit a lot of
many aspects and some of the key aspects
of these cooperative activities and we
engage in cannot be explained by the
self-interest paradigm or the somebody
may be looking idea part of the
explanation is because many of us are
altruistic much of the time I provided
experimental evidence for that and yet
yesterday I outlined a rather improbable
hypothetical history which I think
actually happened and that is that we
became this way
altruistic because of a co-evolutionary
process in which both leveling
egalitarian leveling and warfare played
an essential part today we're gonna ask
how can we use this knowledge to improve
the way we govern our local national and
global interactions whether in
government or in business or in
communities so that we can provide a
flourishing and sustainable life for all
humans but I don't want to start on this
I want you to recall that last night I I
started you on that I know you have this
you have this thing in front of you so
you're not allowed to go and turn the
pages right I I told you about this
problem the daycare centers in Haifa
having parents coming late to pick up
their kids and I told you that they
posted a little sign that said as of
Monday if you come late you'll pay a
fine and of course being good scientists
there was actually an experimental
economist involved two of them they
recorded before this thing started how
late the various groups were this is the
group that had the fine that was the
control group which would have no fine
and the fine starts there and you've
probably spent some time wondering what
happened now what happened actually is
one of the most interesting things
that we've discovered an experimental
economics and if you wonder why I'm now
willing to publish this work when I
wasn't twenty years ago
or any time in-between it's because of
this fabulous outpouring of experimental
work which really nailed down some of
these speculations that I had back in
1988 which I was dealing with more or
less mathematically in terms of
sociological and psychological insight
but I was modeling it but I just didn't
have the goods now I think we do but let
me begin with Aristotle lawmakers make
the citizen good by inculcating habits
in them and this is the aim of every law
giver if he does not succeed in doing
that his legislation is a failure it is
in this that a good Constitution differs
from a bad one not this is one of the
things you would like to see in a good
Constitution this is the measure against
which constitutions should be evaluated
this tradition that we should regard the
problem of good governance as a problem
of somehow cultivating a good citizenry
was an essential part of the
Aristotelian idea and it continued on in
Europe up until about the 15th or 16th
century in at which time sorry to skip
over quite a bit of time there but oh
not only that I'm imposing a little bit
of Italian on you Machiavelli said for
anyone I love translate the Italian for
anyone who would like to order a
republic it is necessary to suppose that
all men are wicked hunger and poverty
make them industrious and laws make them
good that's from his discourses
now notice Machiavelli a genius of
political science did not say that the
laws were to make the citizens be good
in fact his idea in the discourses and
in the prince he's more famous book was
that the laws should induce the citizen
somehow though bad that they are wicked
in fact they should be induced to act as
if they were good and this then became
standard philosophical and political
practical problem that the great
philosophers initially Marcy Leo of
Padua another Italian obviously but this
was of course then taken up by Hobbes
and Hume who were gonna hear from again
today Adam Smith Jeremy Bentham and the
great thinkers of the European
philosophical tradition interestingly
the person who really expressed this
idea was Bernard Mandeville he was a
Dutch doctor by training he lived in
London and in 1705 he wrote this book
fable of the bees of the bees why of the
bees because what he was saying was at
odds with the Aristotelian tradition
which of course was the same tradition
as st. Thomas Aquinas and so on he
wanted to argue something absolutely at
odds with them and had he said that his
book was about human society he would
have scandalized his readers so he wrote
about a hive of bees he said every part
was full of Vice yet the whole mass of
paradise such were the blessings of that
state their crimes conspired to make
them great
there was a hive of bees who were nasty
little animals and yet somehow the hive
worked pretty well and at a certain
point they got religion and they all
turned virtuous and the economy of the
hive crashed and everything went to hell
but before the religion had struck them
the worst of all the multitude did
something for the common good
and his subtitle of a later edition
actually was human frailties maybe
turned to the advantage of civil society
and made to supply the place of moral
virtue now I want you to remember that
there's a substitution here right in
place of virtue we're gonna take shabih
motives and we're gonna somehow allow
them liberate them channel them so that
they convert these shabby motives into
valued objectives in the first lecture I
mentioned this I called it the alchemy
of economics which turns Orden
selfish motives into socially valuable
outcomes in the first lecture I quoted
more extensively but I'm sure some of
you remember about mentioning this again
because a few of you were not here on
first night in contriving any system of
government every man ought to be
supposed to behave that's very much like
Machiavelli but it fell to Bentham the
founder of the utilitarianism in his
famous duty and interest Junction
principle he said in in designing how to
organize a government we should try to
make it each man's interest to observe
that contact that conduct which it is
his duty to observe so there are some
duties which we would like our public
servants to carry out our job is not to
make some moral committed to doing the
duty but rather to provide them with
incentives so that their private
interests will be to execute the duty
which we would impose on them now Adam
Smith's invisible hand famously showed
how self-interest not as he said as I
quoted two nights ago
the benevolence of the butcher it is
self-interest not the benevolence which
will put the meat on the table
Smith's fantastic idea is this let
prices do the work of morals
that's the substitution Mandeville
didn't quite get it
Mandeville is not an economist he didn't
figure out that there was actually a way
that the worst of all the multitude
could do something for the common good
and that is by designing a system of
private property and competition so that
the prices would be such that people out
of self-interest would implement an
outcome which would be in a certain
sense a social order which one could
defend now Smith didn't really have it
fully worked out but the idea resonated
I think it is by the way the single most
radical and most profound idea in the
social science has ever ever written
down it's quite counterintuitive I have
a very hard time teaching my
introductory students that it actually
might work the people who showed that it
actually would work
we're arrow and Deborah Kenneth arrow
one of the original participants in the
Santa Fe Institute a active participant
to this day he founded with some others
the economics program there ken arrow
proved of what is now called the
invisible hand theorem and it showed the
conditions under which Adam Smith's
conjecture would be correct the secret
which was discovered by arrow and de
Brewer made clear by them is very simple
the invisible hand works if everything
that goes on between us that we care
about in some interaction is owned it's
owned by me and then I exchange it with
you and then you own it in other words
if property rights are well-defined
the invisible hand works and now you why
do you need a theorem for that well it's
actually it's a very profound theorem to
show that that is the condition and if
that's the condition then a competitive
economy will reach an outcome which is
in a certain sense efficient now the way
this works is that prices induce me to
act as if I care about the costs that I
might inflict on you or the benefits
that I might incur on you and so that
for example if property rights are well
defined and I inflict a cost on you for
example by driving my car into your into
your house or something
then there are liability rules which say
I have to pay you so in other words the
things which economists call spill overs
that is things that I do that may
inflict either a cost or a benefit on
you should be taken account of in a good
contractual system and when those
contracts are all in place everything
that matters is owned and we're
exchanging these things which we own
according to well-defined rules of
ownership and liability then it means
every actor out of his or her own
self-interest will take account of the
effect of the actions on the others and
then the invisible hand works well
Mandeville's idea was that the right
institutions he had in mind it centers
for the self-interest are capable of
implementing socially desirable outcomes
and noticed the last three words
respective of preferences there's
nothing here about how people have to be
good bad or anything that's really
remarkable we can actually have a good
outcome with prices that essentially do
the job of morals here's an example this
is from another Nobel Prize winner can
arrow of course won the Nobel Prize
James Buchanan did as well
he describes purchasing fruit from his
friend the fruit stand
well not as friendly gasps I don't know
the fruit salesman personally I have no
particular interest in his well-being
he reciprocates this attitude I do not
know and I have no need to know whether
he's in the diarist poverty extremely
wealthy or somewhere in between yet the
two of us are able to transact exchanges
efficiently because both parties agree
on the property rights relevant to them
so here's that idea coming back it
doesn't matter that I have no concern
for him what matters is that we agree on
the property rights now of course what
ken arrow showed and what james buchanan
did not stress is that in most
situations we don't actually have a
system of property rights that works
exactly that way and so the invisible
hand needs a helping hand 20th and 21st
century economists have recognized this
and we understand that many of our
interactions take the form of the
prisoner's dilemma that i've been
talking about for the past two days in
which the self-interest of each is to
the detriment of all or public goods
games which are just an end person
prisoner's dilemma now these are called
market failures and in these situations
adam smith's solution competition for
profits is not sufficient because doing
well in doing good are not the same
thing and there are lots of examples of
this these are well known they're well
known in economics and by the way no
restore see it is absolutely
uncontroversial we have things like
environmental pollution in which i take
some action as a producer or even as a
consumer which has effects on others
financial instabilities and other an
action i take may have effects in other
in other part
to the market product safety in other
words the pursuit of profits has been
shown in many many areas there's a it's
it's really quite endless I could the
list could have gone on working
conditions and so on all of these are
cases in which for reasons that are
pretty well known and pretty well
studied the invisible hand doesn't work
and so the idea is that the helping hand
can be provided by things like green
taxes subsidies for training workers
fines for faulty products now the
question is well are these sufficient in
other words invisible hand plus helping
hand does that work is that good enough
well let's go back to Ken arrow he won
the Nobel Prize for showing how the
invisible hand will work he spent the
time after that showing that the
conditions under which it would work
were very rarefied and indeed there were
many many situations in fact it's the
norm according to arrow that his the
axioms of his famous hand break down
here's what he said in the absence of
trust opportunities for mutually
beneficial cooperation would have to be
forgone norms of social behavior
including ethical and moral codes may be
reactions of society to compensate for
market failures mmm that's getting
interesting is getting preferences back
in and he's saying well no maybe maybe
the idea that of Mandeville's and
Smith's that we can do without the
benevolence of the butcher and we can
just trust that the worst of all the
multitude will do something for the
common good
we have to when we have market failures
perhaps worry about these things
perhaps the helping hand proposed by
economists is insufficient to save the
invisible hand what I want to propose to
you today and I'll give you evidence for
it that I believe is incontrovertible
that is what if trust and social norms
are undermined by the incentives what
happens if the incentives that
economists devised to solve the market
failures actually have a deleterious
effect on people's willingness to engage
for moral or ethical reasoning
now what I call Machiavelli's mistake is
the separable 'ti assumption now this is
one of these points and working on this
lecture Safra bility is a mathematical
concept and many of you here know what
it's about and mathematics is like sex
it's very important and it's even fun
but you shouldn't do it in public
alright so I'm going to give you a
verbal rendition of what we mean by
separable 'ti I think those of you who
are mathematicians are mathematically
inclined will certainly understand and
I'm sure you're happy that I'm I won't
be doing that in public now the
classical writers like Hume and Smith
and others they didn't imagine that
citizens are amoral or that preferences
can't change or won't be affected quite
the opposite David Hume was a pioneer in
studying the evolution of morals what he
called moral conventions and Adam
Smith's other great book was called the
Theory of Moral Sentiments they
understood very well that societies are
run on the basis of incentives and
morality not just incentives but they
did make this one mistake they assumed
that the Moral Sentiments and the
material interests could be pursued
separately in a very particular sense
that policies which are designed to
shape behavior according to the material
interest that is incentives wouldn't
compromise the former that is the Moral
Sentiments in that sense these two
things values and incentives are
separable you can use the word additive
if you want that's close enough having
more of this doesn't alter the
effectiveness of that
that's what separable 'ti means i've
gotten as close to mathematics as i'm
going to go now these propositions the
separable 'ti assumption the fact that
values and incentives are additive has
formed the foundation of modern economic
theories from what's called mechanism
design that's the helping hand guys
implementation theory what's called
welfare economics designing ways of
correcting market failures but it
extends to things like optimal
deterrence judicial sentencing
how to keep kids in school longer and so
on
and because of these are the most recent
Nobel Prize winners in economics we have
Leo hurvich who unfortunate has passed
away
Meyerson and Eric Maskin here is on our
science board at the Santa Fe Institute
we're very happy that he's part of the
Institute's family these are brilliant
contributors to trying to as I say
devise ways of getting around market
failures by designing clever systems of
incentives now as before we have to
define a few words here when the
material interest and the Moral
Sentiments are not separable there are
two ways that they can be not separable
one is they can be complements and that
means they're synergistic that means
that in this case explicit incentives
will somehow empower the Moral
Sentiments make them more salient make
them more relevant more effective in
affecting behavior this would be the
case for example in traffic regulations
most people have bate traffic
regulations out of reasons that they
ought to do so but if you lived in a
society for example in Rome Italy where
I spend a lot of time in which it
doesn't seem to matter I mean you can
park on the sidewalk and you know you're
looking for a parking place and you
notice everybody's parking on the
sidewalk and it's a place on the
sidewalk now and of course this is no
parking now so you're kind of tempted to
do that because there apparently the
regulation isn't being followed so in
other words very but in Tuscany where I
teach it's absolutely the opposite
there's almost no enforcement but if
anybody parked on the sidewalk their car
would be booted or towed immediately and
so and that's so notice the argument
here people are obeying the law in Siena
Florence and so on because they want to
they think it's a decent thing to do and
nobody is actually exploiting their good
citizenship by parking on the on the
sidewalk that's crowding in that's these
two things as complements but they can
be substitutes also there can be a
negative synergy between the two
crowding out is what it is called and
this was famously
baited for a long time about blood
donations tit miss wrote a book a long
time ago about the the fact that if you
pay for blood it may actually reduce the
amount of contributions of blood
interestingly this that idea that of
essentially non-separable 'ti that is
these basic this is a negative synergy
between the two was immediately noticed
by some great economists two Nobel Prize
winners kind of era or one of them in
Robert Solow wrote a review of this book
and they said quite rightly it's an
interesting idea but there there's no
empirical evidence that was twenty years
ago now the question for us today is is
it possible for prices to do the work of
morals does there exist or could there
exist a set of policies laws property
rights and so on such that entirely
self-regarding citizens facing a social
dilemma like a public goods problem
common property resource prisoner's
dilemma the kind of environmental
problems we have problems of
neighborhood amenities and security and
so on
if facing those problems I is there a
way of handling these that so that you
can motivate people to act in socially
desirable way socially desirable ways
means making sure you take account of
the effect of your actions on others or
on the contrary must those who are
concerned about such things as global
warming epidemics spread erosion of
social norms and other market failures
must we also be concerned about the
Preferences that citizens have and the
possibility that economic incentives may
actually reduce that reduce ethical
behavior and not as I implement the
outcomes that we wish and finally if if
the material interest in the Moral
Sentiments are indeed non-separable what
are the implications for the use of
explicit incentives should we use them
more less how can you we can't give up
the use of incentives they're absolutely
essential in any social social order but
what can we learn from this now we come
to this experiment of course you the
this is it's easy to figure out what
happened right because why would I be
putting this before you
that's what happened here we have the
the experiment begins here the define is
announced this is the control group here
they obviously didn't change but the
people who are given the fine
they doubled the amount of lateness they
came twice as many parents are coming
late up here and an interesting aspect
here in week 17 when they stop this
thing quite obvious reasons I guess they
continued coming late now okay just so I
mean you practice using the language in
this case the incentive and the moral
commitment of the parents to come on
time if they could seems to have been
some kind of negative synergy it looks
here like the incentive the fine crowded
out some pre-existing obligation that
the parents were feeling I mean my
interpretation is pretty obvious parents
who probably knew the teachers
personally a bit they felt badly when
they were late you know but I got stuck
in traffic or they ran an extra errand
or something happened and they felt you
know and then the fine is imposed and
they said hot damn they're putting a
price there I can buy lateness just you
know it's it's like a shirt you know and
it was worth it and so not surprisingly
the authors of this paper the the the
title of this paper is called a fine is
a price right it's telling you that you
can buy this thing and notice when
somebody tells you can buy this thing
for some reason which are going to have
to investigate people think that means
that it's a different kind of
interaction and different rules apply
now I want to turn to another slightly
more complicated experiment but it's an
extremely relevant one Juan Camilo
Cardenas is an international fellow at
the Santa Fe Institute he's from you
know University de lausanne days in
Bogota and he has for the past 10 or 15
years designed ingenious experiments not
in the lab not with students but going
to rural parts of Colombia but you know
what's going on in Colombia so that's a
somewhat dangerous thing to do but he's
so far I mean seriously the civil war
happening or it was happening
during this period he goes to rural
areas and he finds a place he's
interested in environmental
sustainability he finds a place in which
people are actually engaging and
withdrawing resources from the forest
and in almost all cases over withdrawing
I said trashing the forest and so these
are rural people he played he does
experiments with them these are it's a
public goods game basically but it's
kind of it's an it's a variant on that I
guess I should explain it to it's kind
of interesting how he does it
the there's a bowl and instead of
putting stuff into the bowl which is how
you do it in the public goods game the
bowl starts out with 50 little nuts or
things in it and suppose you have five
people in the group you pass the bowl
around to each of the five people and
you can take out as many as you like up
to ten when the bowls gotten all turned
around the experimenter doubles
whatever's left in the bowl and then
distributes that equally to everybody so
that's just like the inversion the
inverted public goods game you're all
such good game theorists by now you can
easily figure out that the dominant
strategy remember what that is that's
the thing that you should you you do
better doing that no matter what
everybody else does the dominant
strategy is to take out ten you'll do
better of course you would like nobody
else to take out anything
and that'll maximize what you get but
it's true for everybody so the dominant
strategies take out ten so now the
question is what do people do when they
actually play this game by the way it's
it's a nice design first it doesn't rely
on people being literate you can also
the chair can be pointing in so you can
pass it around people can see what's
going on you can have the chairs
pointing out so then they don't see
they're all kind of variants here so I
direct your attention to this graph here
that's we're going to start with that
the the vertical axis is not how many
they took out it's how much they
deviated from what they would have taken
out if they were totally selfish so that
means that's totally selfish you don't
deviate
you just do the selfish thing take them
all up here that deviation would be if
everybody had deviated six units
whatever they were it was called months
in the forest but if they deviated that
much that would have been a social
optimum but notice to do this much you'd
have to sacrifice a lot of self-interest
and these two groups which in the first
part of the game were identical in terms
of the treatment they were about halfway
in between that is they deviated a lot
from what would have been the selfish
thing but they didn't they didn't
restrain themselves as much as they
should as they should have for the
social optimum and now the red dots are
a group which in this treatment here is
allowed to talk to each other so after
each time they play this game this is
period one period to period three period
four at this point here they stopped and
said okay we changed the rules now now
after each time you play you can have a
conversation it was timed I think it was
five minutes it was also it was taped a
lot of it was videoed which is
incredible they were very fantastic
watching this so you could talk that's
the red group is the group that got to
talk this dark group instead had a fine
imposed on them that is the experimenter
himself juan camilo said if you take out
the wrong amount if you have to deviate
that much or you'll get fined and in the
first round they all did then as the
game went on they realized that the fine
wasn't all that large they weren't that
likely to be monitored and so on and
they ended up down here essentially
being entirely selfish now notice these
are the same people the same people who
here actually gave up a lot of money in
order to do the right thing
once they had to find once they learned
about it they did the exactly selfish
thing now what's your interpretation by
the way here is just saying how much
money they lost that is the these guys
here this this is exactly this graph
here expressed in monetary units now how
do you interpret that well it sounds a
little
like the Haifa case doesn't it that
somehow they were they were doing okay
they were somehow constraining
themselves ethically to not exploit
their fellow group members and then they
did a little better when they
communicated but the ones had the fine
started off doing the right thing and
they declined radically now the I think
the interpretation of that is that once
the fine was imposed it it defined it as
a different kind of interaction actually
one kamila was very interested in the
following problem why do people respond
differently to regulations which come
from the government than they do to
regulations that come from the community
that's what he that was his main intent
and finding out this now finds our
economist think of fines as as prices as
incentives but interestingly
psychologists and sociologists think and
and most human beings think about a fine
also as a signal it tells you something
about your behavior and the way that
it's seen in the eyes of others now this
is a game this is done with Swiss
students again by Ernst fair
you see the name Ernst fair coming up a
lot here we have a person called the
investor technically in game theory
that's called a principal and he
transfers his sum to a trustee who is an
agent the sum of money is given to the
investor by the experimenter and said
you can transfer some money this amount
is then doubled by the experimenter and
then the trustee can give some of that
back to the investor so it's a it's an
interaction in which the investor has to
trust that the other guy will send it
back and then there are a number of
treatments here the first is just this
is the so-called trust condition there
is no fine available and that's these
bars here and what is this telling us
well if I transfer between
four units to you you're gonna transfer
some back to me but if I transferred
eight to ten units to you you transfer a
lot more back that shows that people are
reciprocal now already it's incredible
what's happening here because again
putting on your game theory hats and
imagining even worse that you're
economists you you know how this game
should be played everybody should have
offered zero right because by backward
induction you understand that the person
is not going to give you back anything
therefore why give him anything so if
you really believe the other guy was
selfish you wouldn't have given anything
now notice the actually the reason why
we have no observations here is not
these I didn't give any back it's
because there weren't any that is
everybody gave something now
the then they had this I'm in this fine
in which I I'm the investor and I say
okay I'm gonna transfer this amount to
you hang them transfer ten and if you
don't give me back some amount which I
specify I'm going to find you now the
interesting thing that is if you impose
the fine it's much worse these are these
black bars that is the fine actually
makes people reciprocate less well I
mean that's pretty obvious isn't it
the thing which is going on here is
reciprocation and you reciprocate a kind
act you reciprocate because of your
belief about the intentions of the
person who has offered you this if the
person offers you something incest and
if you don't give me back a lot I'm
going to find you that makes you wonder
or maybe not even wonder about that
individuals intentions now notice the
best thing of all here you also had the
option if offered the fine you could say
the fine is there I'm not going to use
it you could renounce the fine so I'm
giving you ten and there will be no fine
though the the the the trustee knows
that I could have given a fine that's
terrific the white bars having a fine
and not using it now I think I'm
probably on the verge of convincing you
that intentions
really matter that is what's going on
here is using the fine or not using the
fine is signaling to the other guy about
whether I trust you whether I'm a kind
person whether I'm self-interested we
don't know exactly the content of it but
I'll come back to this experiment
because there are a few more secrets
that you could actually tease out of
this but I'll do that at the end now
this is a more complicated experiment
but it's worth it's worth understanding
it basically you could consider this to
be on-the-job learning up until now I've
argued as a kind of a framing or a kind
of a cueing which is going on or perhaps
it's signaling about an intention but I
think what's going on in this experiment
here is actual learning that is I think
that people when exposed to incentives
actually end up having different
preferences that if they come to have
different evaluations of what they ought
to do so let me walk walk you through
this in this case here this is a public
goods game that's the social optimum
that the experimenters again notice
again including fair they designed an
incentive so that the selfish thing to
do was to give 30 and this these are
periods in the game and sure enough the
incentive work exactly that is people
implemented what the incentive said now
it's interesting that unlike the
Colombians they just did exactly right
away what the incentive said then here
they took away the incentive and so the
selfish outcome became this number here
and notice individuals gradually
declined to becoming selfish but only
over a period of maybe twenty periods so
at first they they gave a lot but it
declined well then a very interesting
question is what would happen if they
had the no incentive treatment first
that's here now notice this line here is
a lot higher than that line there it's
actually 26% higher and it's extremely
statistically significant so without
having experienced the incentives in the
first place
they were willing to give more this
behavior is very common in every public
goods game but notice this is they're
just giving more and then when you
Institute the incentive that go right
back to doing the selfish thing so in
other words I think there's something a
little new here experiencing incentives
may make us a different kind of person
in terms of how we evaluate our the pros
and cons and this is the basic idea the
deviation from the selfish thing is
larger if they've not previously play
experienced the incentive now of course
once again I mean there's a there's a
little parentheses or it's not a
footnote because it's too important but
I think this is worth thinking about we
live in societies in which incentives
are highly stressed and if you think of
the human developmental process as one
that goes on over periods of time you
can imagine if this is learning on the
job and this takes place in the course
of a few hours in the lab imagine the
effect that it might have living in a
society in which we are experiencing the
kind of incentives all the time this is
another experiment which I think shows
the same thing that is we actually
change as a result of this this is a
trust game exactly like the one I said
before you give some they give back or
they maybe they don't give back if you
if you look at the top here I'm sorry
that the I tried to put maybe too much
on the page here if you give this much
they give back that much and you can see
you see the same reciprocity as before
if you give a lot they give a lot back
and this is the first round of the the
first phase of the game here's the last
phase of the game there's a missing
phase in between that I'm not showing
you got to tell you what it was here the
intervening state this is the first
round these are all the same and they
look the same there's reciprocity here
that's just repeating the same thing as
that what they did here was they did
define experiment they just imposed a
fine that is I could impose a fine on
you if you didn't give it back and
following that you got a much less
reciprocal response than you had there
their interpretation of this is once
again that people actually learn that as
they become less reciprocal if they
experience a fine heat so even after the
fine is gone they're kind of wrecked you
know by the experience now it also works
a little bit here that's a reward and
that's interesting and we should take
that into account fines may have may
have a larger crowding out effect than
rewards and why is that well probably
one of the things that finds bad about
fines is it finds trashes reciprocity
because it signals bad intent then where
is the reward doesn't so it isn't just
that you're getting money for it maybe
it's the fact that you're being
incentivized means something bad about
the other guy keep that in mind as we
try to understand these things okay
why does separate bility fail I have to
confess I don't know I I am in print as
having provided four reasons I would not
want my life to depend on being able to
identify which reason was going on in
the - experiment and which reason was
going on in the trust experiment I think
these reasons are suggestive I would
appreciate any comments and help this is
the next stage I mean we've we've done a
lot of experiments now and piecing it
together with some interpretation is
obviously step number number two and
step number three is then using that
knowledge as is often the case I accept
the fact that research is an ongoing
process and as I say I've been working
on this for twenty years or I should say
I started this 20 years ago the first
thing that incentives do is that they
frame what type of problem is this
people are good at accepting ques kids
who swear in the street don't swear in
school everybody knows you can basically
cue your behavior on certain things and
incentives say it's alright to be
selfish in this situation
maximizing is okay the now I by the way
you probably remember that if you play
the prisoner's dilemma game and it's
named
the community game people cooperate like
crazy despite the fact that they
shouldn't be and if you call it the Wall
Street game they defect
so that's framing that's just uh you
know it says that's the nature of the
experiment what are we doing here now a
more slightly demanding argument is this
remember I talked about the investor as
the principal and the trustee is the
agent in principle agent problems in
economics of which there are many banker
borrower the bankers the principal the
borrower is the agent employer worker
employer is the principal the agent is
the worker in all those situations
you're devising incentives to try to get
the agent if you're the principal you
try to get the agent to do something
which he or she otherwise wouldn't do
without the incentives so how do you
solve this problem well it's a two-step
process mathematically what you do is
you first figure out the behavioral
responses of the other person and you
formulate that as a mathematical
function given that function you then
say given that behavioural regularity
what's the best I can do what's the best
incentive I can do and then you impose
the incentive and the person responds
well notice this if I impose an
incentive on you I necessarily have to
reveal something about what I thought
about you because the incentive was in
response to my supposition about your
behavioral responses so the the trustee
who who threatens to find you is saying
I don't trust you
the employer who says I'm going to pay
you a decent wage but I'm going to
monitor you with a TV camera and watch
your every move
says I don't trust you and so on you can
think of all the cases in which this
happens so you can convey an intent now
it's not just that I you may convey the
intent of what you think about the the
worker or the trusty lazy unreliable on
reciprocating you may convey something
about yourself for example that you're
greedy or that you're trying to get most
of the gains from this experiment for
yourself I'll come back to that I think
it's important a proposal coming from
psychology actually quite an old theory
has to do with self-determination a
group of psychologists Nisbet leopard SC
and others proposed that people have a
intrinsic desire for self-determination
you could see how natural selection
might have actually encouraged that but
in any case observational a it's
probably quite true if if you provide an
incentive for something which you would
like to do anyway it's called over
justification technically that's what
the term is in psychology and what it
means is I'm providing another reason
for something I would have done anyway
the classic experiments on this I
started off with kids and paintings you
have a group of kids and they come into
a there's two groups in one treatment
the kids come into a room there's a lot
of stuff they can do to play with
including there's some paints and some
of them paint pictures and the same
thing is going on on the other room the
only difference is in one room and the
kid comes back with the painting the
teacher says why Mary that's a beautiful
painting it's it's really wonderful
thank you so much but in the other room
she says Mary that's a beautiful
painting it's really wonderful thank you
so much I'll pay you a dollar for that
okay and then the next day the kids come
back they go to the room and they
observe what the kids do guess what the
kids who got paid for painting don't
paint statistically significantly less
amount of painting of the kids who got
paid for doing it what's that about well
the kids presumably according to the
self-determination theory say it's a
well I like that but I'm I enjoyed the
fact of doing this by itself but somehow
being paid for it reduces the incentive
of me for me to do it by the way
self-determination theory or this
so-called motivational crowding out
doesn't apply to things that you
wouldn't want to do we know there's lots
of good empirical economic research that
incentives work to get people to do
things they wouldn't otherwise do so
we're here talking about not about the
fact that incentives necessarily
backfire but when there is something to
crowd out like the fact that the kids
actually enjoyed painting or the fact
that the parents really wanted to be on
time but they just couldn't be if
there's something to crowd out you have
to worry
the fourth thing is all right this is
kind of a mouthful sorry about that
endogenous preferences well you know
what preferences are and endogenous just
means that they're being generated by
the problem at hand I my students a lot
about I think one of the main problems
in social theory economic theory is to
distinguish between what's endogenous
that is generated by the variables under
study and what's exogenous that is which
you take as given and I had a teaching
assistant at Harvard who reported the
following to me in a review for one of
the our exams he said that he was asked
if there any questions and one of the
students said could you explain again
the difference between erogenous and
indigenous well this um this endogenous
preference is I think you've seen it in
a couple of experiments that the
exposure to the incentives leads people
to act differently even after the
incentives are gone now I don't think
experiments are a good way to study
endogenous preferences I think we should
look and see whether people who live in
societies which have a certain incentive
structure actually behave differently
from people who live in other kinds of
societies the research which I mentioned
before on the 15 small-scale societies
where we did experiments around the
world that was a classic case of being
able to study how if you're a whale
hunter you probably have different kinds
of preferences than if you're a
slash-and-burn agriculturalists and sure
enough that's what we found so we're
pretty sure that preferences are shaped
by the process of making a living and
what we see in these experiments which
is quite remarkable because they take a
couple of hours whereas your preferences
develop over a lifetime but we see it
any way that people seem to be changing
their preferences the examples that I
gave about traffic in Rome it may be
what you would call exploitation
aversion and that's crowding in by the
way that's a situation in which I'm
willing to cooperate as long as I'm
pretty sure the other guys aren't going
to exploit me by defecting and I think
there are lots and lots of examples in
this and there's a there's some very
nice experimental research I mentioned
the work by Toshio yamagishi about
thick and group differences he's also
done some fabulous research on this
showing that being assured the other
members of the group would be punished
by the experimenter means that I'm
perfectly willing to cooperate because I
know that if they defect though it'll
make me angry at least somebody will
punish them so I won't be a complete
sucker now I survey these please pick
these reasons in a recent paper in
science and just in case you hadn't
already figured this out the fact that
it's published in science doesn't mean
that it's true I've already told you
that these are just a list of things
this is the best I could do
actually the editors of science it
pushed me a little further and they said
well what do these things have in common
and I responded look maybe they don't
have anything in common in fact I don't
even know if that's exactly what's going
on they these experiments were not
designed to piece apart what was going
on these experiments are designed for
other purposes so he pushed me and I I
think there is a unifying thread
economists treat economic activity as
being about getting stuff and having it
human beings treat economic activity
both as getting and having but also as
becoming and being that is we engage in
activities so that we can be a certain
kind of person in our own eyes and in
the eyes of others
that's the constituent of social action
it doesn't have to do with acquiring
things it has to do with acquiring a
self so that technically what we say in
economics if somebody is producing two
things at once we call it joint
production any production is joint
production because you're producing a
good or a service and you're producing
yourself in that activity the production
of yourself is what's being compromised
by some of these incentives and I think
we can see it in all of these cases that
there is this constituent of aspect of
that's being compromised
now I said we'd come back to these
trusty guys and you recognize this as
the public goods game from before now I
want to pose a question to you I think I
might know the answer but I
say I was kind of shocked when I
realized that there's a kind of
discrepancy this is a public goods game
these are the periods of the public
goods game and they play the public
goods game at first without any
possibility of punishment so remember
that's just an person prisoner's dilemma
the people could be contributing zero
and they could be contributing 20 and
here they contribute about eleven that's
a bit like the Colombian rural people
who are halfway between doing the right
thing and doing the totally selfish
thing and here they have punishment
sorry they're here if you contribute too
little other people can punish you
remember how that worked at the end of
each round you see on your screen how
much everybody contributed in your group
and then you can pay money to reduce
their payoffs
so this punishment here these guys are
doing is what's sustaining that
contribution level presumably because
people are worried about the possibility
of getting punished if you take away the
punishment it goes down to zero and that
is as I said this is a typical pattern
in a public goods game they just
withdraw now this by the way this is not
the same graph you saw two nights ago
this is last time I showed what happens
if you do no punishment first and then
punishment but obviously in all these
experiments we do it in both directions
because we want to make sure that
there's no effect of which one comes
first and you'll see this this is almost
exactly the same as when you do it
inverted so here you have punishment by
peers and it sustains a high level of
contribution but here when the guy
threatens to punish somebody who doesn't
give enough back it destroys the
reciprocity so I mean isn't there a
little puzzle there why does punishment
in the public goods game work and why
does punishment here fail why does it
backfire well you already know something
about this punishment activity that's
sustaining this these cooperation if I'm
in a group the public in a public goods
game we know that if I contribute to the
group that's altruistic as I defined it
yesterday meaning I would receive higher
payoffs if I didn't do it then I see on
the screen
that Alan didn't contribute and so then
I'm gonna punish him by paying a buck to
said it says to take a buck out of his
pocket and guess what that's also
altruistic right the punishment is just
as altruistic as the contribution so
when Alan is punished by me he can't
possibly think that I have selfish
intent in having punished him because he
knows that I gave up a buck in order to
do that with no prospect of gain by the
way in some of these games they shuffle
the membership of the group's every
period so that you can't possibly gain
by punishing anybody people punished
anyway they love to punish now so I
think that this works because punishment
is altruistic you're not conveying any
bad intent you're conveying good intent
and Alan feels actually a little badly
about that because not only does he lose
some payoffs but he's heard from a
member of his group appear not somebody
up high but a peer who's saying we don't
like what you did now down here in the
trust game we have a different story the
negative effect of the incentives the
fact that this black bar is low when you
use the incentives it's almost entirely
due to the fact that among some of these
investors when they when they impose the
fine they and they asked for a number to
be returned such that if the person
actually returned it they would get
almost all of the profits and the
trustee would get nothing some of the
investors who proposed a fine did quite
the opposite what they did is they
figured out it's not you know rocket
science you can figure out what the guy
would have to give back to you so that
you walk away with the same sum in other
words even they divide the pie evenly
and when you divide the pie evenly you
don't have this negative response or at
least you have a very small negative
response 8% and this was not
statistically significant so now we're
making some progress because here you
can see that the reason for this
crowding out was because it wasn't just
that it was a fine it was a fine with
greedy intent and that's why it had the
negative reaction or at least
that's what I think now in economics
there's a very interesting theorem
called the theorem of the second-best
doodle ipsy and Lancaster and what they
say is that if there a bunch of problems
in the economy and you can't fix them
all so suppose there are a bunch of
market failures and if you can't fix all
of them fixing one of them can make
things worse
so a piecemeal approach moving closer to
the ideal of property rights and
competitive exchange doesn't necessarily
improve things well I think we have a
second best result here where contracts
are incomplete that is you not
everything that's being exchanged is
subject to property rights and hence
where norms may be important in
attenuating market failures as kenneth
arrow said public policies and legal
practices which more closely approximate
the idealized complete contracting
situation that is incentives fines and
so on they may exacerbate the underlying
market failure because they may
undermine socially valuable norms such
as trust and reciprocity and may result
in a less efficient equilibrium
allocation in other words what an
economist would say is improving
incentives need not improve the result
because of this crowding out thing along
with arrows inside now that's why I
think Machiavelli is mistaken if the
error that I've just exposed to you my
second-best theorem about how perfecting
incentives may make things worse if
that's a problem today it's gonna be a
much bigger problem tomorrow and the
reason is this that I call the economy
which we have now left behind the
economy of grain and steel it's the
economy in which a very small minority
of Americans engage compared to the
service economy in which we don't
produce anything you can hold in your
hand or weigh and measure that's called
the weightless economy but all of us
here do almost all of us I suppose we
talk we write we exchange things we
project effects the grain in steel
economy was characterized by being able
to own
the things that it produced it could be
fenced it could be weighed it can be
written down in a contract and therefore
it could be exchanged roughly according
to the principles of the invisible hand
I don't want to exaggerate how well the
invisible hand worked in the economy of
grain and steel but it contrasts sharply
with the kinds of non-contractual
activities in which which are the core
and the heart of the information based
economy these are the people you order
your j.crew shirts from they have
American accents and they have an
American flag there this one is named
saman and this is Susheela there in
Bangalore and they are doing what a lot
of people do they're talking they're
buying they're selling they're teaching
they're taking care of the sick they're
serving food and restaurants they're
doing all of those things which we
simply cannot write down the contract
about what they're supposed to do
because the things that they're doing
cannot be fenced or weighed or measured
you cannot I mean you cannot really
measure what they're doing now why is
that important well obviously it opens
up a huge area of the economy in which
market failures exist and in which can
arrow told us that we should be relying
on trust and similar ethical reasoning
to overcome the market failures now in
the weightless economy coffee and cost
are roughly zero that means copying
programs copying music copying ideas
copying virtually anything which is
primarily informational in content now
that means two things it means that
ownership of goods is difficult it's
very difficult to maintain the ownership
because it's easily stolen and copied
that that means it legitimately but I
want to mention something else which is
even assuming you could enforce enforce
ownership of intellectual property
rights it wouldn't be a good thing
because a good which can be made
available at a zero cost should be
available at a zero cost fundamental
principle of economics is that the
prices which implement the efficient
in the invisible hand theorem there's
exactly this the price should be equal
to the marginal cost that's the mantra
every economist knows that well if the
cost of an additional unit made
available namely copy another copy of
Windows another copy of a song whatever
if the cost of that is zero the
invisible hand theorem says its price
should be zero but if its price is zero
how's it going to get produced we do
have a problem here because the
invisible hand logic fails not a little
bit it fails spectacularly when we get
to the weightless economy now successful
implementation of property rights is not
a good idea
well we net we know that the world is
more interconnected we are connected
with other parts of the world but this
process has been going on of course
since the 19th century the it's a
commonplace to say that but there is
some news and that's this what now
connects us around the world is not is
no longer just the contracts which used
to organize the exchange of grain and
steel that used to be if you look at the
world and how it was connected that's
how the world was connected primarily
but today it's not the seniors of this
newly connected world today include also
climatic effects epidemic spread songs
Computer Applications effect like hatred
love information all things which cannot
be fenced or weighed or written down in
contracts they are important we do them
have these effects in many cases we make
our living doing them these are the
things which are going to determine if
we and other members of this humankind
have a decent life and they cannot be
subject to contract so we're looking at
a massive arena of the areas where kind
of arrow advised us to pay attention to
trust the invisible hand applies to none
of these prices in these areas we'll
never do the work of morals because of
the kinds of dilemmas I just said but
even the helping hand mechanism is
likely to fail
given that government do not have and I
would say should not have the
information and the power to intervene
in the ways which would induce us to act
as self-interested people in such a way
that we would treat these things in a
way which would be socially desirable
when I said they don't have the
information they would have to have
information which would be unavailable
it's unavailable except to people who
are very close to us and provide the
information freely how would a
government extract the information of
how about how much something was worth
to me or worth to you when it couldn't
be priced in the market I can't imagine
it and I would hate to live in such a
society in which a government had those
powers but in any case they don't and
they never will so that adding the
helping hand the invisible hand will
help but it won't be enough now I was
told I shouldn't end on a bad note so I
want to come back to cooperation I mean
remember the good news is that we don't
necessarily have to organize our social
life purely on the basis of
self-interest in some cases cooperation
based both on self-interest and on other
regarding preferences works and
sometimes it works spectacularly like in
Wikipedia or open-source there are
plenty of examples today this is not
something that one imagines might happen
in the future much of what's going on in
the information economy today actually
is already in place people are working
in ways which are not basically based on
the kinds of incentives you see in
markets with kinds of incentives that
Kenneth arrow approved could work under
some circumstances in the invisible hand
theorem utopian you know I'm interested
in hunter-gatherer society the cultures
big men and tribal elders are required
to talk softly and humorously to
deprecate themselves at every turn in
order to maintain their status it
consciously distrusts and despises
egotism and ego based motivations
self-promotion tends to be mercilessly
criticized have I gone back to the ah
Cheh who shared the meat in the honey am
i talking about the lamb Alera
whale hunters who we talked about
yesterday guess again this is a
description of the culture of the
open-source software production
community
described in the book the cathedral and
the bazaar and I think you'll find
similar kinds of motivations in lots of
collective intellectual production
projects including by the way the
research activities in which many of us
engage now I'm not proposing that we
should organize our societies of the way
the hunters and gatherers organize their
societies but I am proposing that some
of the problems we face are not so
different from the ones that they face
they couldn't own the kudu either or the
giraffe which they were seeking and they
figured out a way to chase it anyway and
then share it when they caught one once
in a while just the way software writers
work as part of a team and they they
know it may be years before they
actually come up with a really great app
but they have ways of getting themselves
through that through whatever sharing
methods they have now back to the future
yeah exactly
we now have cost lists virtually
costless decentralized transfer of
information around thousands of
participants and this allows for a
mutual monitoring reputation building
ostracism and other methods which were
common to foraging bands but on a global
scale you know how this works you know
how the trust mechanisms work and for
example if you look at things like
Wikipedia and so on and the editing and
so on these of course we're never
available to small-scale societies but
it's the same idea you monitor you
ostracize you ridicule and you get
people to shape up because they want to
be seen well in the eyes of their
fellows ok the conclusion is the
Constitution for knaves in either its
invisible hand or its helping hand
version is not going to provide a system
of incentives which will promote
adequately a flourishing and sustainable
world today a future given that we are
in a weightless economy and a global
village now connected by sinews of non
contractable exchanges which are
essential to our well-being the good
news is that were not knaves at least
not all of us all the time social order
contrary to Hobbes and contrary to men
Caen and the cynics contra even to
Alexis de Tocqueville's Americans who he
ridiculed social
has never been relied on solely as has
never depended on self-interest fit to
be maintaining social order would surely
break down if indeed we were knaves and
the whole project of trying to design a
society that which would somehow work if
we were all knaves seems to be actually
quite preposterous our altruistic
predispositions this legacy of a hundred
thousand years of evolution does provide
an essential resource it's one which has
to be recognized mobilized and empowered
now that's crucial because notice I've
shown you I think that incentives can
actually demobilize and disempower those
dispositions for altruistic behavior
what is empowered well remember the
public goods game with punishment
suppose you have a public goods game
with no punishment and you have two or
three selfish people and six or seven
unselfish people and the selfish people
don't contribute then what are the what
are the altruistic people do well pretty
soon they don't contribute either
because they they're getting angry at
the people who are free riding on them
so a few selfish people can induce
everybody to act as if they were selfish
even the ones who aren't selfish but
exactly the same thing is true in the
other direction when you add punishment
to the public goods game a few people
who are civic minded are willing to
engage in altruistic punishment can
induce people who actually are selfish
to act as if they were generous well
this is a really interesting problem
then for Constitution building it's no
longer that we have a group of people
who are homogeneously this or that we
have a heterogeneous population of
people who could go either way and
whether you're going to empower the
civic minded or whether you're going to
empower the selfish ones is a choice and
we know something about how to do that
and so as a coda the basic problem of
institutional design is not to find a
way to induce a homogeneous population
of self-regarding individuals to do this
desirable thing I presume to update hume
a person who I greatly admired I'm sure
I could not improve on what he's written
but this is what I would now say in
place of what he wrote the task of the
policymaker the juror
the person designing incentives
including the employer at the banker is
to devise rules incentives such that in
cases where cooperation is socially
desirable other regarding preferences
will be sustained that is you will not
essentially obliterate them crowd them
out and individuals with these other
regarding preferences will have
opportunities to express their
pro-social predispositions in ways that
induce all or most others to cooperate
as in the public goods game with
punishment so that's Hume rewritten now
that doesn't get us in a very
comfortable place because contra the
philosophical foundations of
philosophical liberalism and an
agreement with Aristotle what this says
is the policymaker like the parent or
the teacher must be concerned with
inculcating habits the government cannot
avoid being concerned about the
Preferences of the citizens it is a
liberal cop-out to say oh we say nothing
about people's ends and their
preferences that's up to them now by the
way I'm not advocating that the
government should get in the business of
changing people's preferences I'm
telling you that's what governments do
what do you think schooling is about
it's about inculcating habits what do
you think teaching nationalism is about
that has to do with changing people's
preferences but what I've shown now is
in very subtle ways designing any system
of incentives is likely to affect the
values and objectives that people have
there's no way of avoiding it so the
choice is not should the government get
into the business of being concerned
about people's preferences we know that
already they are it's it should we talk
about it should we talk about it as a
democratic community what kinds of
preferences do we really think are
better
don't tell me please that you are unable
to think about that it's too hard those
of you who are parents think about it
all the time imagine being a parent and
not being able to speak with conviction
and with some knowledge about what it is
you're trying to do with your kids or
imagine those of you in the room like me
a teacher
you sometimes think that one of the
things you're trying to do is to
inculcate habits of for example loving
science being an honest scholar and if
you don't think that I'm surprised I
think that was very nice wasn't it I
mean I that's all I'm gonna say
it's just surprised now by the way I
know something about societies which
have a dictatorial predisposition
towards organizing culture I think Jeff
mentioned that I was a musician in the
Soviet Union for I did two concert tours
there I saw what happened to musicians
who did things which were not allowed it
didn't happen to me although the police
did try in a number of occasions to
close down the concerts that I was doing
but they did things like for example not
allowing the two jazz musicians in my
group to play a jazz concert until the
huge protest at the Leningrad
Conservatory was done I know a lot about
the dangers of governments being
involved in shaping values firsthand so
I'm not saying this because I think it's
easy I'm saying it because I think it's
inevitable I think we're doing it and we
should start talking about it I want to
thank my many co-authors and my many
critics again here is the Santa Fe
Institute that's the University of Siena
actually right there is my office and I
want to thank the Cowan Endowment at the
Santa Fe Institute in particular which
has supported this massive massive
project involving literally dozens and
dozens of people that have allowed me to
stand before you to introduce you to
these ideas I hope you don't think that
I invented them this came out of a
process of literally dozens of people
talking over years arguing trying to get
it straight probably getting it wrong
still some of the time and here in a
shameless non altruistic step I will
tell you that some of this is in a book
of mine called microeconomics and here
are some other papers that you may find
interesting this is the weightless
economy in action my American English
language publisher of course insists
that you pay money for this
but I managed to negotiate with every
other publisher the Spanish the Russian
and the Italian and presumably some
others as time goes on
free online editions so while it's crass
for me to advertise this i really
suggest you really should read the
Italian or Russian or Spanish editions
thank you very much
we have a bit of time for questions and
comments I have appreciated very very
much the comments in the last two nights
and don't feel the need to put a
question mark at the end of your comment
just let me let me hear what you think
and where you think this should go and
what's wrong with it yes
okay what well first if if you have a
friends piece of music you can put it on
your iPod right now that doesn't cost
you something like you know it's a
little bit of bother but or consider the
music in the first place a CD costs
about 20 bucks on the market what does
it cost to make another CD available
it's less than a buck that is the cost
of actually producing one more CD what's
the difference between the buck and the
well that's paying for the musician
that's paying for the advertising it's
paying it's paying to get the stuff
actually done in in the first place so
people who study information economics
distinguish between the first copy cost
which is a huge sum for a CD and the
marginal cost the marginal cost is I
mean that's an eighth that's actually
that's not unusual that the that the
marginal cost may be one twentieth of
the price now remember with what the
economist tells you is the price should
be equal to marginal cost that means the
price of the CD should be less than a
buck but it's 20 dollars so I mean we
don't have to quibble about whether it's
really a buck or a zero I mean the point
is it's you know it's if it's a factor
of 20 different sure sure
I I absolutely agree the fact that the
person has to eat and and so on all this
other things you said doesn't alter the
fact that having one more song on their
iPod doesn't cost them much if they have
an iPod
they don't have an iPod they're out of
the game yeah
mm-hmm
people obey property rights because it's
the law and they feel morally obliged to
obey the law and they feel that this is
something they're willing to engage in
even when it inconveniences them because
over a very long period of time studied
by Hume and Smith and others we have
learned that respecting property rights
is a good way to organize a society so
that this moral injunction to not
violate property rights is backed up by
this very powerful argument that
organizing societies according to the
respective property rights is a good way
to organize the production and
distribution of whatever we need now in
the weightless economy the last
statements that I said are wrong that is
we still have a moral obligation one
presumes to have respect to property
rights but the backup is gone there is
no backup anymore the the argument that
you should respect property rights just
deontological II that is as a commitment
fine that's something which I think
people rightly have but the fact that
you should respect property rights
because that's a good way to organize
society is just wrong when it comes to
the things I'm talking about now much of
the world as the previous questioner
probably has in mind much of the world
is not so worried about putting songs on
their iPod they're worried about putting
shirts on their back and food on the
table and in those cases that still is
the economy of grain and steel and it
would be a terrible travesty for the
economy of grain and steel if property
rights were violated on a grand scale
we've already seen what happens when
that when that happens so we really have
a bind we have an economy now which is
going to be for the foreseeable future
mix between one in which property rights
work reasonably well I don't mean to
exaggerate how well and one in which
property rights work extremely badly and
by the way I mentioned information but I
could have mentioned pharmaceuticals and
I could have mentioned a whole bunch of
other things in which the stories that
you get about you know treatments which
cost a dollar to make available being
priced at 50
or 20 bucks and therefore unable to be
used in many parts of the world it you
know you find the people from the
pharmaceutical companies on TV they look
horrible I mean they they say well look
how are we going to get this stuff
produced and then there's this member of
it South African NGO saying yes but do
you understand that we could be curing
these diseases and it only cost $1 to
make this thing available and you're
charging his fifty bucks and the guy
looks sick right but I mean that's
unfortunate for him but he's saying
something real that is a real problem
you can't just say the price should be
zero without saying how are you gonna
get the stuff produced now we have a lot
of very very very intuitive very
interesting and creative ideas about how
you separate the production of this
stuff from its invention that mean that
is a one-word answer you've got to
separate the incentives get get the idea
they're the first copy cost you got to
separate that from producing the pills
or whatever how you do that is a big
that's a big big research project going
on right now yes
yeah of course I mean the I mean I
obviously housing I mean it's it's a
combination of things it's the housing
has boomed and wages have sagged and the
combination of those things
I mean it's very interesting calculation
how many how many hours would you have
to work at the average wage of an
American production worker to purchase
the average house sold in America that
has gone way up and I mean that's I mean
and and therefore you get the problems
you're talking about now if you think
that kids living with their family until
they're 30 is a really good thing then
if we're doing it right that's what
happens in Italy by the way I'm but in
Italy it's called mom ISM that is
because the Italian guys really like to
live with their moms I think it's
because they don't want to do their
dishes or something I'm not sure yeah
i altruism evolved in human society
because of group competition and i
believe could not have evolved any other
way a very an important aspect and how
that works I'm sure you recall that
basically the groups with a lot of
Alturas survive in a competitive process
with groups which have fewer and that is
why they can win in the horse race
against the fact that in every group the
alturas are doing poorly compared to the
non altruists he's war necessarily
involved someone kindly asked me a
question last night couldn't we
basically be non parochial altruist and
I answered yes were it the case that the
competition between groups was a kind of
invisible competition in which a group
over here in a group over here were
struggling against the environment and
the one with a lot of co-operators
survives and these guys over here die
out and then these people come over and
take their land but after they're
already gone yeah that's a scenario that
could work
now as I said I think the evidence is
overwhelming that humans did have a lot
of warfare in their past and I didn't
bring it up to the present but I I could
very easily the last half millennium in
Europe is a wonderful example I mean
brutal example but a perfect example of
the kind of group selection whereby
certain forms of government and certain
forms of citizenry simply were
eliminated and what was the process war
that was it one word war the ones who
won the war are the ones who survived I
mean just one one word about history in
Europe there were something like five
hundred separate entities sovereign
bodies in 1450 five hundred some of them
are called bishoprics some of them were
actually place is ruled by pirates some
were free cities in southern Germany
some of the city-states of Europe some
were Kingdom's small ones some were
called empires and so on a huge variety
organized on different terms by the
beginning of the First World War there
were 26 sovereign body
left standing and this in this great
shakeout which eliminated more than 450
of these states a single form survived
that's what we call the modern
nation-state in that modern nation-state
they had done a few things that worked
they had established in most of the
cases private property they'd
established a system of Taxation which
most people paid they'd established a
kind of nationalism whereby people are
willing to go to war against others in
other words they'd cultivated a certain
kind of citizenry and they survived
because of war now does that mean that
in the future we'll have to rely on more
in order for this to continue absolutely
not
for the very same reason that I said
parochialism racism ethnicity and so on
may have been our legacy but it's not
our destiny I feel exactly the same
thing we don't need warfare to promote
altruism in fact of course it's
extraordinarily dangerous yes
no no I mean I think first I as I said
at the end of my last talk there is no
evidence that any of this stuff is
genetic but it could be but there is an
evidence for it why do I use such a
simple model well here's the task guys I
set out for myself I observed that
humans are unique among animals in the
ways that we cooperate so I'd better
have an explanation that works for
humans but doesn't work for all the
other animals or otherwise dogs should
be doing it right so that's the job is
to figure out a model that works for
humans but not for everybody else and
that means taking account of humans and
specific abilities so that means I'm
building into this thing some stuff that
humans do but virtually nobody else does
now so I'm both know they're there they
do they do some of the coordination but
they don't do it among non relatives and
yes they don't they related
that's how slime molds it means it
that's a funny you should mention that's
the paper that Steve Frank Fred which I
quoted yesterday so there are all kinds
of things that are unique to humans
which explain why we have this unique
trajectory so I mean I not only am
resisting you know you're suggesting I'm
resisting building in special things yes
I want to build in special things
because I don't want this to work for
every other animal
now how many special things do I build
in well you've got me on that I mean you
know as you as possible and it may be
that some of the things that but but but
by the way culture is definitely on the
table remember all the stuff about
culture gene coevolution but it could
have happened just culturally the the
the the the model yesterday all that it
requires is kids get stuff from their
parents doesn't matter if they get genes
or if they get behavioral
predispositions through teaching and as
I said I did the gene stuff because I
thought it was harder that's all yeah
way up the back no it's not true at all
know the difference between an apple and
a say a song is that the cost of the
Apple at the store is approximately what
it costs to produce the thing and making
more apples available in the store will
cost approximately what the price of the
Apple is making more songs available by
me giving a song to all my friends it
doesn't cost anything other than as you
point out maybe some minimal copying
costs that marginal costs does not mean
am i inflicting a harm and other people
if I should steal it and so on
marginal cost means something very
specific it means what is the additional
cost meaning of resources that have to
be used so as to make an additional copy
available and you know the evidence is
overwhelming the marginal cost of
information goods is very very low
compared to the price so the Apple is
not like a program now what you're
saying is by stealing somebody's music
I'm inflicting a cost on the author or
the musician that's true that's true
yeah but but let me urge you to separate
your last point which is correct from
your first point which is not correct
yeah okay yeah
yeah I love to consider what happens in
the public arena as experiments and I'm
always looking for them I mean the
experiment has to be that there's some
shock or there's some change that then
you can actually see what the impact of
that is in an experiment we have control
groups and treatments I hadn't thought
of that
however but I do it all the time and now
I'd like to take one more question I I'm
pleading a little bit of my own for my
own convenience I'm I've got a plane at
6:00 a.m. tomorrow morning from
Albuquerque so I have to get I have to
get down there at 5:00 or something yeah
thank you for thank you
hmm well I'm really glad you asked that
question and I'm glad I called on you
but I wish I could call on all of you
because your question is exactly what we
should know but we don't that is I mean
it's it's quite striking the experiments
are pretty persuasive and by the way I'm
not hiding some experiments from you
there and this is what they say so you
would expect them if the experimental
results are so robust that you could
find in the real-world cases in which
you've you have exactly that kind of
thing happening now the haifa daycare
was not actually an experiment right so
it just it's called a natural experiment
because the people didn't know they were
named affirm and there are other cases
like that and so we're beginning to
accumulate evidence but as you say the
difficulty in performing experiments or
better yet finding them like they did in
haifa is that typically when something
changes like a new incentive or
something like that
it's other things have changed too that
is you almost never see a pure change in
something without confounds that's why
we do experiments in science and the in
in some areas of science it's pretty
easy to draw inferences from the lab to
the to the real world in these social
science experiments we don't yet know
anywhere near enough about what's called
the validity of the experiments because
finding the real experiment in the world
like the haifa day care center which is
really pretty clean it's very hard to
find so now that's a very interpretive
thing you read case studies and read
studies like for example blood donations
the supposition that blood donations
might be reduced by paying was poo pooed
by ken arrow and robert solow
although they thought the idea was
interesting well now we have lots of
experiments about that and it turns out
that in there I think the best but there
are two experiments both suggest that
there is some crowding out in one says
there's crowding out in women but not in
men and others crowding out with
everybody so we're gonna find out some
of those things but it's very very slow
and in part it's just because we're just
sort of getting on top of the
experimental evidence now and we don't
even really under
saying what's happening but the question
that you asked is the way we have to go
thank you all very much thank you for
all of your comments
you